le voilà enfin notre héros de guerre et
de retour au bercail tu as bien fait de
revenir ici parce qu'ici les
Osages sont les meilleurs des plus
magnifiques créatures au monde mais ce
sont des gens avisés
seuls à qui revenait le pétrole
parle-moi de toi même les femmes c'est
mon grand péché
de se mélanger assez familles mais
l'argent du pétrole coule dans la bonne
direction il coule vers nous
c'est ce que vous êtes et rien compris à
tout ça mais je parie que ça veut dire
beau diable en indien
[Musique]
pourquoi vous êtes venu
je bosse avec mon oncle
il vous fait peur
non
le plus gentil du monde
est venue il faut que tu reprennes le
contrôle de ta maison
j'ai envoyé par Washington je viens voir
pour ses meurtres
on a tellement de morts qu'on a perdu le
compte mais ça peut aussi être le manque
de chance ça ressemble plus à une
épidémie qui a de la malchance pour moi
des mains de l'ennemi ne les laissez pas
mourir seul le mal encercle mon cœur
faut que tu restes à ses côtés
[Musique]
il y a des fois où
je te crois bien sûr que je
t'aime alors tu sais un blanc qui en tué
ma famille
et elle a dit qui elle redoutait le plus
[Musique]
surtout ne fais pas une chose que tu
regretterais pour le restant de tes
jours
[Musique]